[Música]
el mar menor es la laguna más grande de
agua salada de Europa con una extensión
de 135 kilómetros cuadrados podría ser
un entorno idílico si no estuviera
masivamente contaminado
Victoria ha vivido cerca de sus orillas
Durante los últimos 50 años dice que hoy
en día no se le ocurriría darse un
chapuzón en el agua
era un mar sobre todo y principalmente
transparente
limpio había caballitos de mar era un
mar vivo y ahora es un mar Muerto
todo esto está lleno de algas
no se puede resistir el olor a huevo
podrido de momento no se ha hecho nada
bueno perdón si se ha hecho se ha hecho
destrozar un ecosistema como este
los activistas creen que el cambio en el
ecosistema se debe a la contaminación
urbana y sobre todo a la agricultura
intensiva cuando las algas se vuelven
demasiado densas impidan el paso de la
luz solar y es imposible que otra
vegetación produzca oxígeno
en los últimos años la falta de oxígeno
ha matado a miles de peces
en 2016 el 80% de la vegetación
subacuática estaba muerta para evitar
más destrucción ecológica José y su
colega patrullan regularmente el mar
menor
cuánto tenemos de visibilidad
1,4 metros
en el punto cada semana estos
investigadores controlan la calidad del
agua Les preocupa especialmente la zona
de la laguna cercana a la desembocadura
del albujón es el punto más lejano del
Mediterráneo es una zona sensible ya que
realiza el agua termina en el mar menor
y es una zona donde las corrientes y
demás pues son un poco Menores
en el laboratorio el análisis es
irrefutable
Y estos son los niveles de nutrientes
que deberían estar en 1,8 como máximo y
vemos Que en profundidad llegan a 4,5
que es un valor tres veces superior al
normal los ecologistas creen que algunos
días se vierten hasta 5 toneladas de
nitratos en la zona Holanda qué tal
la muestras un poco alto si lo
comparamos con el patrón
los nitratos provienen de las 60.000
hectáreas de tierras de cultivo que
rodean el mar menor el 20% del pib de la
región procede del sector agrícola
Vicente es agricultor y cree que su
profesión ha adquirido una imagen
injusta aquí estamos criminalizados De
hecho hay en algunas zonas de la costa
carteles que la verdad es que bueno pues
no sé pintada agricultores asesinos
agricultores criminales para reducir el
impacto de la agricultura los
agricultores de la región aportan
100.000 euros a un proyecto de
investigación Los investigadores
estudiaran si el agua salada de los
depósitos subterráneos contaminados
poder recogerse y desnitrificarse
primero desalinizan el agua ya que la
sal retiene los nitratos a continuación
vierten la salmuera en este tanque
Buenos días restos de podas de limonero
o de cítrico con este tamaño
aproximadamente que esta madera al
mojarse libera carbono que es necesario
si el alimento que van a utilizar los
microorganismos que hay aquí de forma
natural
encargados de eliminar los nitratos que
trae la salmuera dependiendo de la
temperatura podemos obtener un 75 o un
90% de eliminación de nitratos entre 8
horas o 24 horas si se utilizará a gran
escala este procedimiento produciría
enormes volúmenes de salmuera y nadie
sabe aún dónde podría verterse sin dañar
el medio ambiente el mar menor la mayor
laguna de agua salada de Europa unida al
mar Mediterráneo se ha convertido en el
primer espacio natural de Europa
protegido como entidad jurídica en la
universidad de murcia Teresa Vicente fue
pionera en la batalla para que la laguna
adquiriera el derecho de ser protegida
conservada y restaurada es una norma
jurídica la norma jurídica de mayor
Rango que es la ley y esta ley contiene
derechos subjetivos para la naturaleza
para el ecosistema del mar menor porque
se le reconocieran derechos Como a una
persona o a una Corporación
cualquier ciudadano o personas jurídica
puede ahora presentar una demanda En
nombre del mar menor para defenderlo y
también se creó un consejo compuesto por
ecologistas políticos y agricultores
para garantizar la protección del
ecosistema
a las grandes corporaciones agrícolas se
les va a citar para que su voz también
se oiga pero tienen que aprender que ya
no es cuestión de que ellos quieran o no
quieran es que el mar menor tiene
derechos y los derechos del mar menor
coinciden con los derechos de las
corporaciones esta nueva ley ha dado a
los lugareños nuevas esperanzas de que
la laguna pueda recuperar su antiguo
esplendor sin embargo Los investigadores
estiman que el ecosistema tardará al
menos 20 años en regenerarse